the funny thing happens is the this
whole process of deciding you're going
to take care of your money now some of
us are nerds I mean even before I did
this stuff I just I would sit down you
don't remember the old checkbook
registers never you're old enough to
remember old checkbook registers in the
back of your checkbook before there was
the web and before there was the
internet and you would write down you
know every check and then you would put
your bank statement there was a physical
paper bank statement with the actual
physical checks would come in the mail
each month and you would check off the
checks in the statement and make sure
that the right amount was charged the
amount that you had written down and you
would reconcile physically reconcile
with like a calculator that's what they
have these things called calculators
back then physically reconcile your
checkbook and really know what was going
on I'm the guy that did that from the
time I was 16 on just I'm that big a
nerd
I really am and some of you did that now
I mean with the internet and you know
you can online banking you can balance
your checkbook and about what reconcile
your checkbook in about what 30 seconds
now it doesn't take time at all it's a
very very fast to do you know people
don't even realize they're doing it
hardly anymore it's but it's a good
exercise and but I was that nerd most
people are not that nerdy I mean I had
yellow pad lists I always had a list
before there was a budget there was even
a list you know and you know always
sweating it worrying about it you know
fretting over most people don't do that
most people have an experience like that
last caller they're going along in the
south we call it ditty bopping they're
just Diddy bopping along kind of in a
phase kind of in a haze kind of foggy
but everything's good as long as there's
no bumps in the road there's no reason
to try to steer the car different it
just we're just rolling along here and
then something happens is a big layoff
at work they didn't get you but they're
probably gonna get you next time
transmission goes out on the car antenna
heta dies halfway across the United
States you gotta buy our airline ticket
you know any money to go to the funeral
you want to buy a house that was last
call right something happens it goes you
know I probably look at this money thing
I don't pay attention I'm gonna start
paying attention and the first thing
that happens is you kind of start making
these lists in your mind you don't
really write them down because you're
not as nerdy as me and and but the fog
starts to clear and you start to go you
have an oh crap moment don't you like oh
crap this is a mess I got that last
caller I got $6,000 in collections and
oh and there's this oh no moment right
and you kind of get the sweat going you
know remember the sweat usually like
right above your lip a little bit in the
palm of your hand
sometimes a little bit right above your
eye your eyes dilate your heart rate
increases and you're like oh crud I got
a problem here this is like grown-up
stuff I'm gonna actually have to pay
attention that's the first thing that
happens is you realize there is a
problem that is the best day of your
financial life if you let it be my dad
used to say 90% of solving a problem is
realizing there is one you ever meet
people who have misbehavior in their
lives but they're not self-aware enough
to know it they don't even know there's
a problem they're oblivious they're
unconscious about life and about their
problem
they're never gonna fix it cuz I think
there's a problem they don't know
there's a problem it's the same way with
your finances you're not gonna fix it
until you know there's a problem
the best thing can happen is you go
there's a problem oh my gosh there's a
problem then you start to realize I'm
the problem it's my fault
no one did this to me I'm not a victim
it's my fault well unless you want to
play the victim and if you won't play
the victim you can always go I'm a poor
millennial I of student loans in the
society is taking advantage of me or you
can play all that crap but most people
just go it's my fault I screwed up what
am I gonna do and this sense of Oh being
over
is very real changes your heart rate it
stresses your butt out that is awesome
as long as you do something about it
because if that that's in psychology
they call that dissonance and if that
that inconsistency that dissonance in
your life says I'm gonna move away from
this pain towards something that fixes
it you will move towards doing your
budget and when you do your first budget
you will have this release moment like
you breathed in cool mountain air like a
sigh because when you do your budget and
you really detail everything out
very seldom are things as bad as they
felt when you didn't know the details
not knowing the details is a monster in
the closet the boogeyman is in the
closet and he's never really there as
bad as you think he is
now some people discover it's worse than
they thought it was but very few most
people when they write it all out I mean
that lady made $80,000 a year she had
$15,000 in bet I mean you guys listen to
this show that's just nothing
I mean people pay that stuff off in 20
minutes listen the show they but you
know but she was completely freaked out
in the corner like oh god this is so bad
because she hadn't moved to that next
step yet of writing it all out in detail
combing the tangles out of the air and
when you do that you're gonna discover
we've got the money to fix this and when
you do that first budget that's why I
always tell people you feel like you got
a raise and the reason is you feel like
there's not enough money when you're
overwhelmed you feel like oh we're stuck
oh my god oh we're gonna die and you go
into drama queen mode right but as soon
as you do the budget it call calms down
it's like you know I think we can do
this I think we making up where's all
the money going oh we got to stop doing
this and stop doing this and sell this
and all we got to do is this and and you
have all the all we got to do moments
all through the thing right all we got
to do is all we got to do is and it's
readily apparent to you people with
common sense right there as soon as you
write it down and you do that budget you
feel like you got a raise because you
can see how you're going to get traction
to win this is why three million people
use every dollar I
online budgeting app that's completely
free for your iPhone or your droid the
reason 3 million people are using it is
they have that moment and they go I'm
gonna have to be grown up there's a
phrase going around the new phrase that
cool kids use I'm adulting we're adult
has become a verb being an adult as a
verb I'm adulting have you seen that
yeah it's a cool way of saying I used to
be a child and now I'm gonna act like
I'm a grown-up even though I've been
walking around the grown-up body for
maybe a decade now I'm adulting but
that's all it is is you're deciding I'm
going to be grown-up I'm going to take
responsibility for my actions my future
my destiny and even my past I'm gonna
put it behind me with a plan and I'm
gonna execute on a plan this is why
every dollar the app is exploding
because it's giving people the power to
do that if you're really ready to get
control the first step is you have that
oh crap moment
and then the second step is you begin to
do away with the anxiety that comes with
that moment by laying out a plan a
detailed notified plan the good news is
we've been doing this so long it only
takes you about 10 minutes on every
dollar you do all this with like 19
yellow pads and stacks of bills on your
you know all over your kitchen table you
know you just can't get more and more
and more stressed out but you jump on
every dollar it's designed to help you
put the thing together quickly and
easily I did I mention it's free and did
I mention that there's 3 million people
out there that seem to know something
something you don't know don't wait
until you have an oh crap moment just
decide oh I'm going to adult let's see
how used it is a verb but you see I did
that that's pretty good I'm gonna adult
I'm gonna get on every dollar I'm gonna
be a grown-up this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]